so how are you doing I'm good I'm I'm
I'm energized I'm like I'm having fun
good okay that's good to hear
like I was just saying I absolutely love
this movie and and I left the screening
and I just sort of you know I was like
I'm gonna try and you know do a little
research on doppelgangers see what the
deal is and I went down like a like a
rabbit hole like a completely I didn't
even think of that
mm-hmm for lack of a better phrase it
went down a rabbit hole I'm wondering
how much of that you did how much you
explored the lore and stuff like that or
did you just start with the idea of like
seeing yourself would be scary so I
started with that idea when I was
younger and and when when I decided to
make this project or was exploring it I
went on this down the same rabbit hole
where I tried to get to the bottom of
why doppelgangers is the is fairly
universal you know just about every
mythology has some version of the
doppelganger tale and there there tends
to be a harrowing Menace attached to the
mythologies as well so yeah I did I did
some research mm-hmm and and I also
while I was you know it's just sort of
compiling stuff about this movie and I
saw something from Fangoria that said
that they wanted you on the cover but
you said I'd rather put my monster on
the cover so they put Lapita on the
cover and I'm wondering when in the
process you realized that you were you
were creating a monster not just a
character but you know a classic-car
monster that sort of you know lives up
to the Freddy's and the Jason's stuff
like that well thank you that's that's
that's very high praise I
that was the goal from early on and I
was like I want to make a monster movie
I you know I think part of it is you
know when you see a charismatic and well
designed monster it is magnetic and and
you know the tradition of monster
stories I think empathy lies underneath
it you with Frankenstein for example you
are terrified of him but
you are also invited to relate to him
and empathize with him which i think is
such a fascinating someone during how
involved you are with stuff like set
design when it comes to Easter eggs and
stuff like that I kind of noticed that
the first shot you can see sort of chud
and the man would do brain stuff like
that is that something that you very
specifically like I'm gonna you know
just slide this into the to the right of
the camera or that just yeah I I focus a
lot of attention on these little fun
moments but also my art team Ruth de
Jong and her team you know have very
clear orders to fill it up with Easter
eggs and can make connections so it's
you know really at a certain point
everybody on set knows how I'm working
so somebody could come up to me be like
oh you know what this is kind of like
that thing that and that can be
incorporated it really is this it's it's
a collaboration and over the years we've
seen people like James Wan and JJ Abrams
sort of create their own little horror
universe I'm wondering if that's ever
you know crossed your brain that you
have get out and this movie out have you
ever thought of you know sort of
connecting them or keeping them all
within the same universe doesn't be like
that yes I have thought of it is there
anything you'd like to elaborate is
there anything that we should be looking
for is that if that's something you want
to save completed for the future save it
okay completely understandable well like
I said I really love this movie and I'll
say congratulations I could ask a
thousand more questions but I think I
should just tell people to go see it so
thank you man that means a lot
you